hello everyone this is the Volgin and
welcome to skip rewind number five the
show that informs you about some videos
that you may have missed and also goes
over some SCP related news as well but
you also may have missed I haven't
actually made an episode in about two
weeks I have been very busy creating
stuff for patrons and also just videos
so anyway and off enough excuses let's
just get into it starting off with the
videos that you may have missed no I can
only include five cards for you to click
on so only gonna mention five because
there's a lot there's a number of videos
that I've done over the past couple of
weeks that have done very well and you
most likely have seen so I'm just gonna
go through the most noteworthy ones and
the most recent ones
the first one is scp-610 the flesh that
hits the only reason I'm including this
in the video because this was quite a
long video it took a long time to record
and I'm really happy with it
so if scp-610 is something that you like
go and check it out because it's one of
the ones that I'm most proud of recently
the second one is it's it was it was
kind of a joke but I created it will
look with a straight face and that is
scp-049 guided meditation this was my
first attempt at trying to do an ASMR
video um if it's not your thing I
completely understand it's not really my
thing either but I get so many people
asking me to do it not for 50,000
subscribers I thought why not it's not a
big deal it's just another idea if it
works it might be something else I could
do for my channel it didn't really do
that well but if anything the script is
actually taken from a legitimate website
that is meant to guide you through best
like a sleep meditation so if it's only
just for that
Jaka day the third one is SCP 29 12
Cloney climb climb this was a kind of
weird Leon salad one I don't really have
a phobia of climbs or anything but yeah
if you haven't seen it I don't want to
spoil it but it's kind of unsettling but
a good idea as well it was really
enjoyable to read the fourth one is SCP
3063 it's just simply called a fly this
won't disturb me for very obvious
reasons and that is it involves ice
flies I he had everything to do with
house flies The Associated story and
kind of lore behind it it's very
unsettling and creepy but also
mysterious which i think is why a lot of
people like it so check that out if you
would like to hear about some gross
stuff it's no and finally this is the
collaboration while my site of the
collaboration with SCP Illustrated if
you don't know I voiced one of his
videos and he voiced one of mine and I
have tried to illustrate a SCP for the
first time and it's really fun so I
probably end up doing something like
this again this was more of a cartoony
episode because it was it was a joke SCP
so I thought a cartoony style would suit
it so yeah I was really happy with this
the video is done quite well as being
quite well-received so yes out of all of
them I think check this one because it's
the most different of all the videos
that I just mentioned and that's it so
well that further ado let's move on to
some SCP news the first piece of news is
quite important to me anyway maybe not
to you but I was involved in the
creation of an SCP yes I didn't do any
of the writing well I helped a little
bit but I done some audio recordings
doctors sumerian asked me to do it i
made it and he was kind enough to credit
me in the creation of the SCP it is SCP
30 at 13 the
all of hyperion so if you haven't heard
of that yet go and give it a read
because I think it is pretty good its
ratings are quite good and only rising
on the SCP wiki right now so go give it
a read and read it positively if you
liked it the second piece of news is
it's kind of a quick one but SCP unity
posted the new model for scp-106 and it
looks pretty impressive I like the way
they've included a jacket on at 9 that
looks pretty cool I can't wait to see
that implemented in the [ __ ] it may be
already and I unfortunately I haven't
installed SCP unity please correct me in
the comments if it's already implemented
SCP unity is a fantastic take on
containment breach so if you haven't
actually got it like me like I should go
and get it if you're a fan of
containment breach because it's
essentially just a complete visual
upgrade it's still in development
obviously but it's cool to check out the
third one is kind of quick as well but
Lord bung actually posted his versions
of Cain and Abel in kiss he ever adds
the men to confinement what if what I
what am I gonna say here it's Lord bung
it's obviously brilliant
check the might I was with everything I
mentioned here in the description that
will be links to everything that I
talked about so if you want to get a
better look at it I know this kind of
VHS looking thing isn't really the best
for detailed view but that's kind of
would be encourage people to go to the
actual creators and see it so very cool
artwork from Lord bung on the fourth
piece of news is there was a screenshot
was released for an upcoming game called
SCP redacted and it might be a little
bit too early to judge but visually this
game looks top-notch it looks vaguely
like a triple-a title almost I mean I
might be jumping the gun a wee bit
because it's really one screenshot but
it looks really good right I'm very
excited to see where CP redacted is it's
not it's not that SCP unity is bad at
all I'm really looking forward to that
but it would be good to see referring
like the IKEA Guillaume three-zero-zero
it I think that was a new tick on an SCP
game it's always good to see new
creative TX on it so I hope it's
different from containment breach
because I'd like to see more variety but
that was pretty cool
and finally saving the best to last the
SCP wiki turned 10 years old a few days
ago it wasn't precisely today but it was
a few days ago and that's that's awesome
we should be celebrating the wiki
staying alive for this long for me
personally I'm a bit biased because you
know the site completely changed my life
I have a borderline job because of it
now it has some of the best most
creative people in its community I have
made so many friends because of this and
I hope it goes on for twenty more years
it certainly has the potential to
because the SCP foundation is just a
bottomless pet for creativity that's one
of the reasons why I love it so much so
on that sentimental note this is where
the episode ends thank you all very much
for listening I hope to see you all next
week
fingers crossed and have a lovely day
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Andre Bessette
thank you very much Andre your pledge is
very much appreciated if you would like
to know how you can get a personalized
thank e at the end of each of my videos
as well as some other really cool stuff
as well go to patreon.com/scishow and
thank you